from neo to john wick viewers just can't
stop hitting pause
in analyzing frame after frame of keanu
reeves movies
there are too many unforgettable moments
to count throughout his career
but these are the ones that truly stand
out above the rest
while the famous proverb states hell
hath no fury like a woman's scorn
it may have to be updated to say hell
hath no fury like john wick after you
kill his puppy
when we meet this former hitman he's
living a quiet life of retirement while
grieving his late wife but after the
bloody assault on his new beloved pet
he understandably desires revenge so he
smashes open his basement floor in order
to access the secret cache of weapons
he's buried beneath his home
thus irrevocably plunging him back into
the world of assassins
this particular scene is frequently
paused by fans because it makes you
wonder
what exactly is wick going to do with
that sledgehammer that he just happened
to have lying around
this moment also shows the grief and
desire for vengeance that consumes him
along with the fact that the dog was a
present from his wife
whose death left him completely
shattered the sledgehammer is the
viewer's cue that this seemingly slow to
anger guy is about to go ballistic
the full weight of everything wick has
been going through
loss sadness the need for retribution
makes this clip among the most
pause-worthy of reeves's entire career
who can resist soaking it all in when
someone demonstrates how lethal a pencil
can be
in john wick chapter 2 the immediate
aftermath of his takedown of a couple of
assassins in a coffee bar gets us so
hyped up that we simply must rewind and
repeatedly digest reeves awesomeness
after a multi-million dollar bounty is
taken out on wick he's forced to fight
off a posse of killers who step
up to claim the booty by closing the
open contract on his life
in this game of assassin pretty much
everyone is willing to take a shot for
that much money
no matter how well respected the target
is wick is able to fend off his
attackers by eliminating them with a
simple pencil
proving a writing device can indeed be
mightier than a sword
once killed three men in a bar a pencil
i know i've heard the story fans of the
wick franchise might want to take a
break at this moment to drink in the
full scope of the impressive display of
violence that's just been unleashed
not only does wick end two men after
he's been wounded
he adds to his own lore about how he
killed three men in a bar with a pencil
witnessing him actually performed this
feat confirms that he's a badass capable
of turning just about
any seemingly innocuous object into a
deadly weapon
the image of him holding the bloody
pencil after doing the deed
sums up the emotions we experienced
while watching it
things get even dicier for john wick in
his third film
when he finds the elder who's
essentially the leader of the underworld
he's given a choice
die immediately or pledge loyalty to the
high table
he chooses the latter option so he then
removes his finger and gives his wedding
ring to the elder as a show of fealty
this is easily one of the coolest scenes
it demonstrates how wick's desire for a
peaceful life is often forced to take a
back seat to the seemingly endless
obligations incurred by his history of
underworld violence
so why is this scene worth pausing it's
all about the graphic intensity and the
artistic culmination of so many plot
elements
wick's commitment to honoring the memory
of his wife his efforts to get out of
the underworld lifestyle
and the respect he holds for his allies
at the continental
all unite at this moment his severing of
his own finger reminds us that he is a
man of focus
commitment and sheer will accepting
disfigurement
certainly proves just how far he's
willing to go
the scene in the matrix in which neo
ducks backwards to avoid gunfire is
definitely iconic
it's the first image that immediately
springs to mind when you say the phrase
dodging bullets as neo and trinity
attempt to rescue morpheus
they're ambushed by agents on a rooftop
agent jones takes over a nearby body and
begins the style of weaving and bobbing
around the bullets that has become
synonymous with the matrix franchise
when jones fires back
neo bends over backwards to avoid death
with reeves delivering arguably the most
famous
moment of his career it also represents
a huge leap forward in cinematic visual
effects
there are so many reasons to grab the
remote and study this scene
frame by frame over and over again
there's the sight of the bullets flying
across the screen over reeves body
the way his arms flail in the air as he
bends backwards
and the bullet barely grazing his leg
this moment
also sets us on the path to believe that
neo is indeed the chosen one
who will destroy the matrix and free the
people once and for all
in the force awakens when kylo ren froze
poe dameron's laser with the force
many fans were triumphantly drawn back
into the world of star wars
but that wasn't the first time that a
main character showcased this ability in
a major sci-fi action flick as keanu
reeves fans are well aware
neo had already performed this same feat
12 years earlier in the matrix reloaded
before this unforgettable sequence
happens neo and company are headed to
the merovingian
in order to rescue the key maker who can
get them access to the source of the
matrix
after some hijinks involving the
merovingian's wife neo manages to rescue
the key maker
only for the merovingian to then corner
him once some henchman
opened fire on neo he calmly puts his
hand up and brings the bullets to a
standstill
thereby providing us with one of the
most unforgettable images in the entire
series of films
this moment is worth pausing not only
because of neo's freezing ability
but also because of how effortlessly he
does it when the henchmen open fire on
him
he puts one hand out and brings the
bullets to a standstill
all while maintaining the same calm
demeanor that he typically wears within
the matrix
his laid-back attitude in the face of
death has a huge effect not just on the
audience
but also the merovingian upon witnessing
this display he remarks
okay you have some skill
the image of neo preparing to face down
agent smith one final time in the matrix
revolutions
unquestionably belongs on anybody's
shortlist of keanu reeves most paused
moments
after finally making it to the machine
city neo encounters the machine's leader
deus ex machina he's able to broker a
deal in which he stops agent smith from
taking over the matrix in the physical
world
while the machine leader spares the free
human city of zion
the leader agrees and then neo is
inserted into the matrix to begin his
duel with agent smith
after smith goes on a monologue about
how the purpose of life is that it
should end
neo gets up and strikes that famous pose
although this is hardly the first time
that neo has taken this stance
it rises above all the others thanks to
the sheer swagger that he displays
despite the long odds that he faces he
chooses to stand up when smith
knocks him down and confidently beckons
at him as if to say
come at me bro neo's willpower
determination and refusal to stay down
are what make this moment profoundly
special
can you feel it mr anderson keanu reeves
has starred in his fair share of
comedies
but no scene in his career has provided
more laughs than the one and always be
my maybe
when he comes waltzing into a high class
restaurant in slow motion while awol
nations
sail plays in this scene randall parks
marcus and vivian banks jenny have gone
to meet
ali wong's sasha and her mystery
boyfriend at the restaurant
after the three gets settled sasha's
boyfriend arrives fashionably late
and it's dramatically revealed that she
is in fact dating keanu reeves who is of
course played by reeves himself
while reeves screen time in this movie
amounts to a mere 14 minutes
he makes the most of it he takes all of
the hyperbole that's been said about him
over the years and pokes as much
fun at the audience as he does it
himself as he arrives in slow motion
both marcus and jenny's mouths fall wide
open
which works as a parody of people who
put reeves on a pedestal
by having him play into the assumptions
that people have about him
he lures the audience until laughing at
themselves
1989's bill and ted's excellent
adventure
was reeves first real blockbuster and
the scene in which the two title
metal heads discover the existence of
time travel remains one of the most
memorable moments of his entire career
reeves ted and alex winter's bill are
working on a high school history project
that will determine whether or not they
pass their class
and although they don't know it yet it
will also decide whether their band will
become the basis for a future utopian
civilization
while they sit outside a circle k
convenience store working on their
assignment
a strange man named rufus arrives from
the future
to ensure that bill and ted succeed in
their mission his appearance is soon
followed by bill and ted from the future
and then hilarity ensues the look on
ted's face as he attempts to comprehend
the strange things unfurling in front of
him
is why this sequence makes it onto our
list his exaggerated ignorance adds to
the farcical nature of this
scene by playing into many of the
stereotypes about dumb high schoolers
including the number 69 always being on
their minds
even though this movie was released more
than 30 years ago
this scene has managed to retain its
most excellent entertainment value by
appealing to teenagers of subsequent
generations who are still alive and
kicking
oh and ted give my love to the
princesses
who you'll see
few keanu reeve scenes are lingered upon
more than the one in
speed in which he hurls himself from a
car onto a bus
while both vehicles are barreling along
at over 50 miles per hour
reeves plays lapd bomb defusal
specialist jack travern
who must deal with a man who's
threatening to blow up a bus full of
people unless he's paid 3.7 million
dollars
jack and his partner harry race to catch
up to the bus and stop the extortionist
before it's too late
once they catch this speeding vehicle
jack makes the decision to join the bus
riders
thus providing us with an all-time
classic action sequence
jack jumping into a moving bus ranks
among reeves most paused clips
because of the shock factor as well as
the bravado that he displays
the wow element in jack's fearlessness
in a moment of crisis
gets our hearts racing and set the tone
for what remains to come
in one of the best action movies of the
90s keanu reeves taking a stroll through
hell in 2005's constantine
like it's no big deal makes for a
surreal and totally pause-worthy moment
when a woman named isabel dotson utters
constantine's name before jumping off a
tall building
her twin sister angela goes to
constantine to figure out why isabelle
killed herself
constantine then decides that the best
course of action
is for him to transport himself to hell
to find the answers that angela seeks
the image of constantine walking among
demons in hell makes for one of the
coolest keanu reeves moments
because the cinematography is simply
amazing from the howling winds blowing
fire to the general post-apocalyptic
atmosphere
the setting alone makes for an
incredible moment then the demon zombies
giving chase to constantine as he tries
to recover a medical tag
really hammer in the gravity of the
danger that he's in it all combines for
a moment that you'll want to slow down
just to soak everything in
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite actors are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one